hello there yes you sitting through yet
another unending Zoom meeting or the one
procrastinating on that thing you should
be doing do you ever feel like your work
day is a groundhog day of meetings that
could have been emails and emails that
should have been meetings you know
you've tried everything to break the
cycle extra shots of espresso upbeat
music even motivational posters like the
ones with a cute kitty hanging off of a
tree branch with a hang in there written
on it and yet here you are watching the
second tick by wondering if this is what
the next 30 years of your career will
look like stuck in a loop of monotony
and your creativity and zest for work
slowly dwindling you spend onethird of
your adult aweight life at work surely
this is not what it's supposed to feel
like right right what if I told you that
I can help you transform this endless
loop into a blessed daunting experience
or dare I say even an enjoyable one what
if I told you that you can find meaning
joy and yes even after in the same job
that now feels like a chore this isn't
about finding a new job it's about
revolutionizing how you experience work
with the right tools a dash of humor and
A New Perspective I'll show you how to
breathe life into your work days and who
am I to make such outlandish claims well
my name is Drew Tarvin and for the past
12 years I've been successfully teaching
people how to efficiently use humor in
their personal and professional life
what started as a quest to deal with my
own disengagement at work turned into a
lifelong mission to help you harness the
power of humor I've done that by writing
books through one-on-one session
speaking on stages and through private
corporate workshops and now I'm here
teaching you directly here are some of
the stages I've spoken on see take a
look yeah not bad and also these ones
now I'm not flashing these logos to brag
although speaking for the FBI was kind
of cool I'm saying this because this
experience and the proprietary tools
I've built over the past decade make me
uniquely qualified to teach you how to
improve your own work environment
because I can't force your manager to be
more generous with their positive
feedback and I can't necessarily
convince your leadership to pay you more
but I can teach you how to be more
visible diffuse a 10 situation and
Achieve better work life balance and
that's exactly what I'm going to teach
you in this course a fail proof
stepbystep method on how to
intentionally incorporate humor at work
and at home to create meaningful
connections with co-workers and fellow
humans to become more memorable to
improve productivity relieve stress and
to Simply have more fun to you know
enjoy life if you're into that sort of
thing so join the make work suckless
program and I promise you'll learn how
to stride into work with the nuisance of
confidence and don't believe me well
here what people had to say yeah these
people and these people had a good point
as well and overall you get the
message listen you don't have to
absolutely despise your job to join this
program even if you love what you do
there's always room for improvement
right this is just about enhancing your
work experience by adding a spark to
your daily routine and injecting a dose
of fun that can make good days great and
tough days a lot more bearable it's not
just about fixing what's broken it's
about upgrading your whole work life so
whether you're in a dream job or just
biing your time this program offers you
tools to make everyday brighter and more
enjoyable after all why set for good
when you can have
spectacular ready then what are you
waiting for let's make work suck less
today